I was wondering how how well you've
adapted to all like the let's say the
online lingo and the online memes I'm
struggling what's your favorite meme now
I just found out what down bad means I
thought yeah you you always you do keep
saying I'm down bad I thought it meant
like at the gambling table I was like
I'm down bad like like I thought I was
losing money I'm down bad or it's like
in the video did you get weird looks
from like the ladies I get weird
looks bad you look at the and you're
like man I'm really down bad today yeah
Mak sense to me or or like I'll be
playing like a video game and I like on
Twitch or something and I'll be losing
subsequent like you know s game I'm I'm
down bad and then and then everyone I
guess that's similar to I really am
horny yeah yeah that's so stupid we've
adopted it's more like desperate oh
you're desperately one thing that you
also kept saying at some point is that
you and as as a use for excited you
would say I'm bricked up yeah I'm all
that makes sense man I'm all bricked up
I'd be like are you ready for the day
he's like I'm bricked up and I'm like
what the [__] so I'm taking those words
back so I like I'd be you know I'd be
did you ever have those words no but I
want to reestablish what they mean so
yeah he'd be like all right today's a
big day we have twitch Rivals I'm like
I'm all bricked up I'm ready to go what
does that mean break up means you have a
a [__] erection yeah it's brick it's
brick it's like a brick like a
brick all right I mean technically
you're not wrong I guess like you're so
excited you have like I'm bricked up
bricked up all right is ready but the
meme stuff it just happens to fast and
it and I'm okay with it it's like no
one's ever going to believe it and it's
fine but when I was the age where it was
more accessible to me it it was
something that was natural memes or
joking or you know certain vernacular or
certain okay what what what are you some
of your like classic memes then actually
if I'm being 100% honest I'm pretty
ashamed what in the early n the late 90s
early 2000s a lot of the the meme stuff
was really offensive and so yeah like a
lot of slows it was just really bad and
like and I think that even near the tail
end we all kind of got away from that
and it was like but I would say things
like do people still say that's sick or
badass or those are still I mean like
memes only came out like
like 10 years ago like advice true
that's not true that is true wait wait
Trace Your Meme history memes have been
around since like late '90s early 2000
we're
talking I swear to God the [__] cat
hieroglyphics and like the [__]
ancient Egypt those were like their
version of mem no no no swear down swear
down man kill Roy is the original meme
the World War II little guy
you I was talking specifically about
internet memes interet been around since
the internet no they haven't no they
have no the wild west of the internet
was a glorious place where there was no
rules established there was like the
best page in the universe this was the
most popular site to talk about jokes
about from this one guy and it's no
longer really referenced anymore at all
the first meme I can genuinely think of
is all your bass are belong to us I mean
that's the classic fire all Zig K can
you Google what is the first internet
meme cuz I'm I'm genuinely curious I'm
going to say it was probably an advice
animal or the dancing baby from Al baby
no that's from a TV show rle copter
copter
dance uh all your Bas belong to us there
we go all your B are belong to us so I
law that's that's where if uh a
conversation goes long enough on the
internet it'll eventually reference
Hitler yeah so that was yeah it's a trap
yeah but see like hamster Dan hamster
dance that's a yeah that's is still not
yep there I
wasy that's Ali mcel
came yeah just looking at that graph is
really funny yeah it's true it's but see
like that's but the internet really came
out like 95 96 when it started becoming
pervasive with like how like with
Napster and downloading music and there
was no memes yet there was and like even
that stuff it was like 95 96 no [__]
way yeah and then it was shut down
I I was I was born after Napster no you
were not I guess I was when Metallica
ruined all the Metallica said [__]
Napster yeah that was good times man
that was good times that's an amazing
zero and like all of the kind of but
like I I would say meme culture didn't
become meme culture until really Justin
TV or twitch when it was more
universally adopted I totally agree
because I remember there was this moment
in my like let's say like YouTube
history where everyone you know I've
always tried to make comedic kind of
videos try try to like put jokes in my
videos and somewhere along the lines
they stopped calling my jokes jokes and
they start calling them memes I can't
tell when that transition was but I
never changed the ways I started making
my videos that's true you never hear
someone go oh that was a good joke yeah
yeah yeah right oh that Meme was killer
y he's meing joking yeah and I don't
know when that transition happened but I
remember when I first saw it I was like
I'm not making a meme I'm just just
making a joke
I don't know what the difference is I
guess if it's like more referential it
would be a meme do you have a favorite
era there was like the ones where you
would have like a Bad Luck Brian that
was a whole era like the pictures
inspirational posters black back and
then the white outline the
uninspirational post like gingers they
have no
souls and then I'd say like after that
one and then Bad Luck Brian and stuff
you had like the gifts were a big part
of everyday conversation for about four
years I me they still I'd say they're
slightly
SK cringe gifts are getting more cringe
now now it's static images are coming
back I'm try I'm trying to think because
it depends on if the GIF is something
that you've seen so many [__] times
before you know if it if it's like a
fresh one like OC huh original content
well there's one that's been going
around recently which is the one where
it's Vince McMahon going like oh yeah
like
this that's more I I wouldn't put that
in like gift territory though that's
just more of a funny video meme I don't
know I think reacting to like how many
times when you use Twitter or instant
messenger do you go to the do you go to
a gift reply these days I mean I I've
never done that okay but I've I've just
never like I mean I did that on like MSN
and [__] that's like 20 years ago do you
do you do you send emojis when you
message someone I I Emoji I emoj I know
you I know you Emoji I know you Emoji
yeah sometimes I feel like I should but
I sometimes do I do it just to make sure
that like my tone is conveyed yeah
sometimes I look at a sentence I'm like
it's not getting across something's
missing oh crying laughing emoji that's
I feel like feels very it feels very
like like an exchange otherwise if
there's no emoticons to it's like we are
sending each other necessary information
and that's it whereas an emoticon I feel
like adds more context add emotion to it
my favorite ones are the ones where like
when you're texting someone and you're
clearly trying to be sarcastic but if
you just read the text it doesn't sound
sarcastic until you put the skull emoji
on yeah yeah then that's the one then it
becomes I love the skull emoji it's so
good I don't think I can use it when you
put a skull emoji immediately it's like
it could be the most it's like it could
be the most positive thing and then
immediately become sarcastic I think I'm
out on that one I think well I mean I
like it but I think if I used it they'd
be like okay Pete you're nice
try and it's like getting carded at the
the
Barcade I trust me I'm still like had a
great dinner fork and knife and I'm like
you still that's that's a bit that's CR
but that's what calls to me so anything
else would be trying too hard to do you
just see all emojis like that no I mean
I there are some that are universally
okay like the Clapping one can be useful
yeah it just depends on the context but
I'm not really familiar with how to
tweet yet so and I'm not ever going to
be so I just kind of probably better off
F I'm okay with it I'm better y but
watch change since the old days yeah did
do you remember like Tech speak at all
oh yeah leite speak kind was it called
lead speak 1337 speak like I like own
Zord you and like you yeah all that [__]
was awesome yeah like dude I still
remember the PW and
pawn you got Pawn you got pawned like
you said a pawn it was prawn prawn yeah
it's not still I still use that as like
a joke prawn yeah yeah it's a great PR n
yeah PR zero n if but lead speak was
even during the era we it was always
ridiculed like it was only used
derisively to make fun of it in of
itself I I don't feel like it was I feel
like there are making fun of you no no I
I I I felt like there was a period where
people unironically said it and then
after that kind of cycle like went
away I think it had a very short
lifespan where people were actually
using it unironically and a very long
lifespan of people using it ironically
yeah that might have been it that's how
most of my my vocabulary forms just
saying [__] ironically and then I'm like
wait I'm actually I think I'm doing this
on I yeah
toally that's so haunted like dude was
never in my vocabulary I never said I
never said dude but I us started using
it ironically because it was just a
funny word that was that was me with
bruh and then now I I unironically used
yeah that was me with dabbing 2016 every
photo remember remember the Joey dabbing
era oh yeah
plank uh I still don't know what that
means I thought that was a sex thing I
thought it's like Prince William likes
getting planked I thought that was a
phrase is that not the phrase or is that
like Peg I think it might be Peg does
Prince William I don't know what either
of I thought planking and pegging was
the same meme no so I think it's pegged
yeah it's Peg yeah it's pegs so I I I
saw that did you partake and Begg no so
I because I was unfamiliar with phrases
I just used them interchangeably I just
never did any of I see I just I just
imagine being like yeah so I saw my
friend the other day doing the pegging
challenge well pretty epic video so
what's planking is that where you do the
thing on your your wrist wait yeah
technically but the p uh the pegging the
the planking challenge was where you
would literally just lie down face down
on the ground like you're plank of wood
and the more extreme of the place you
would do it the the bigger challenge was
and there was like a lot of people who
died doing this because they would doing
them on like like train tracks on like
train tracks and like on like the the
handrails of like balconies and stuff
like that and they just fall off yeah
people people died doing this why you
looking at me like you said it this also
reminds me what he didn't realize oh
this was bad this sucks I thought
harambe died of natural
causes I don't understand I thought it
was a tragic story and then everybody
told me he was shot this is [__]
stupid yeah he was assassinated he was
murdered so that's why everyone wanted
Justice for him bro harambe would be
disappointed how do you think he just
died of natural CES again I I knew the
child fell in yeah and and what he just
had a heart attack yeah I thought heed I
thought he died of shock and then
everyone was like they need bigger
fences so to protect these apes and I
thought like he the the child fell down
and then he was like and
then and I thought that's what killed
him and then somebody was like no they
called in like the zoo sniper staff yeah
I can't the video is like absolutely
horrifying like he's literally dragging
this child and it's not his fault I just
couldn't believe it because I'm pretty
sure I was in Japan during this time and
so news
travels 2016 yeah and so I missed all of
this I I missed rest in peace rest in
now that I know you were brutally
murdered he didn't just well since
you're in Japan did you like ever was
graun ever no or con for president or
something I don't know oh my God I you
are just bringing back like a core
memory that
I Cony is a corrupted Ugandan warlord
what I thought it was like a Grassroots
movement in New York who would hire
Ugandan children into his armor well
well I mean okay this a whole yeah so I
thought this was like a green party
thing in the United
States and it's it's
like how did you think this well because
it was con 2012 was the slogan yeah I
understand but since I only have heard
the slogan I don't have any reference
point because it would never come up in
day-to-day discussions while you're in
Japan and so
there's yeah and so you know you miss a
lot of those flasho things that are
important to a lot of people from
because but how did you equate hot
attack how har just thought it was a
tragic I don't know I just made it the
[__] up it didn't make sense that they
would shoot an ape in an enclosure I
just thought that was that that's why it
was a tragedy yeah I mean it makes sense
now and so is Con 2012 a tragedy
apparently so like I'm learning con
story is a little bit different well I'm
just saying these were some sort of meme
or like like not memes but these were
moments that people had in the western
world and I I was locked out so like in
which this is going to sound really in
which year did you kind of like sh cut
yourself off or like you know cut become
cut off from like inet culture 2011
until about
2016 that's when so many good events
happened is that because of Japan like
moving there yeah when I my first year I
was in nigata and I didn't even have a
phone for my first months like I just
went completely off the grid and I
couldn't afford like a uh like a laptop
or anything I didn't have a computer
until I started like Twitch streaming in
20 21 2020 but I'm also jealous that you
get to like relive these like in a fresh
eye yeah well it's it's sometimes tough
when you don't have any context and
you're obviously wrong yeah because like
so many so many modern memes nowaday
require like 10 different levels of
context for like a single image yeah and
yeah there's a lot
ofay mes there a lot of memes that are
like four layers of memes in one it's
like what is this who is this for what's
the latest meme that you learned of I
mean it's it's like it's so hard to keep
track I mean like even the one we just
referenced about in Vince McMahon you
know like you see them so much now that
I feel like I actually kind of preferred
not being a part of meme culture like
there's a real freeing sense of of just
not having to reference this for comedy
but at the same time it's like being at
a concert or like a sporting event or a
twitch stream where you do feel part of
a collective group when you do know
what's being
referenced I'm obviously out of that LE
one thing I was surprised by is uh I
because initially you didn't talk about
it much but you have an intense love for
sports I do I'm very I love sports
sports literally all of them like I I
really enjoy following Sports I enjoy
playing Sports what's your favorite my
favorite is baseball and because that's
it's America's pastime and it was
something that was very closely
connected with me and my dad and so like
that has that familial thing yeah but
basketball um baseball I've always
wanted this phrase America P time
American P what what does that mean so
to put it simply as an American baseball
has such a deeply rooted history with
when we were coming out of the
depression and you may have heard of a
player named like Babe Ruth he's a
famous there's a candy bar is also named
Baby Ruth he was like great one of the
greatest basball he probably arguably
the greatest baseball player ever
there's even terms now you'd say it's a
ruthian task which like a Herculean task
the reason baseball's so closely
entwined with American history was that
one guy became the first famous sports
player in American history so much so
that it we believed if Ruth can do these
things by God so can we and it was like
that part of
American motivational and so I mean
baseball for over 100 years was such a
vital part of American culture until the
past 30 and then it's dead I mean I feel
it was kind of the same when baseball
was introduced to Japan as well very
much like cuz that was you know uh post
you know World War II and everything and
you know it was before the economic
bubble happened and I feel like a lot of
sports that were imported from other
countries to Japan that are now massive
like baseball uh you know we like kind
of used to being like yeah all right you
know got this yeah right on I think
that's why that's such a huge kind of
like sphere of like American kind of
like Fascination here with a lot of
people from Japan oh yeah I I actually
just went to a bar last week and the guy
running the bar was uh the best way I
can describe it was just an American
otaku like that's great though like and
it was like so he was like this old guy
and he just had like baseball cards and
everything those called America Boos
like
amoo yeah and he was like yeah I was
like watching the game and I was like
what game and he was like all the
games every single game well like in
Japan especially like past 5 years like
America core like that kind of whole
like looking at America through the like
rose tinted glasses like when it comes
like style and fashion and just like
decor and stuff it's huge in Japan yeah
yeah yeah so many secondhand stores are
just like selling these like America
core items and you show this to an
americ they're like America doesn't like
there is always a sport game happening
every single night like of like a big
league it seems in America almost
certainly yeah seemed like every single
night you'd go into a ball and there
would be a game on it's great and so
that that got like through college the
NBA has 40 games and 40 nights during
the playoffs so it's a pretty like
nostalgic thing to be working on exam
papers and just know that you're going
to have some sport on in the background
so um but I mean obviously when you look
at me it doesn't I don't give off The
Vibes that I I love sports but I it is
something that I still follow pretty
regularly to this day I mean I I think
liking Sports and following Sports was
kind of like at least my age just kind
of like a given and it was like more out
of the norm to not follow Sports and now
I think just because we're so integrated
into like let's say nerd culture
especially online culture now it's now
you're like the outcast if you do follow
Sports if you are passionate about
sports I don't watch a lot of sports but
I really love the the stories that have
been that have taken place in sports uh
even if I don't care about the the the
sport at all but you know there's like
some American stories that from like
American football that I've heard that
I'm like that sounds really cool but I
don't care no no the Olympics the
Olympics do this the best when they
always get some Narrative of like this
one person's swimming goal and then you
get all wrapped into it for that one
event and yeah American Sports are good
kind of over like that in the I think
what like American Sports football in
the UK they're really good at like
having these longstanding stories that
develop over the course of the years I
watched that Emperor lemon video about
the 72 dolphins or whatever oh the
undefeated team yeah yeah that was
really cool like when it's framed in
such a way it's like oh this is great
like I I love watching documentaries and
and uh movies whatever about about sport
but I don't want to watch it week by
week a lot of the time and that's is
that's is the sometimes Legends Final
sometimes it's worth it though when you
have when you have a team do any teams
you support I do I have my my beanie
that in my my bag here it's my Kansas
City Royals beanie which is a baseball
team they are the worst team in the
majors but I will never forget that in
2015 they they won the World Series and
it's the first time in 30 years that
this had happened and to be at school
when this was unfolding and being a part
of it oh man there's nothing better and
then they immediately went back to the
worst team in the entire world